you know failed former president Donald  Trump made a lot of noise about  announcing something on November 15th  and he did announce on November 15th  that he's running for president again  and even the people in the room didn't  seem that into it in fact a lot of them  were trying to leave and were stopped by  Mar-A-Lago security or staff and ever  since then nobody really cares and in  fact a number of new polls have Trump  losing to Ron DeSantis who hasn't even  declared that he's running now I'm not  going to fall into this Trump can't win  stuff we saw how that went in 2015 2016  was oh Trump can't win he's got two  percent in the polls  there were 20 candidates then Trump was  not a former president completely  different situation but needless to say  we don't want to get into that but if  you are a former president  and you're the only one that's declared  and you're losing to people who haven't  even announced that they're running it  doesn't exactly project strength